it is february 10 2022 and you're
watching the code report the most
trusted name in tech news the neat thing
about cryptocurrency is that it's
trustless and that means when you put
your hard-earned paycheck from wendy's
into a crypto exchange and somebody
steals it you'll probably never get that
money back but simultaneously it's not
an anonymous safe haven for criminals
either your classic lose-lose back in
2016 somebody stole 120 000 bitcoins
worth 71 million dollars from the
bitfinex exchange by accessing the
private keys of users today those
bitcoins are worth 4.5 billion dollars
making the hackers some of the richest
people on the planet but there's just
one problem bitcoin is a giant public
ledger and you can't move your money
around without the feds watching your
every move and last week they recovered
94 000 of the stolen bitcoins and
arrested the husband and wife duo of
ilia lichtenstein and heather morgan
ladies and gentlemen
we got him
the saddest part of the story is that
heather was an up-and-coming rapper
[Music]
at least now she does know where she's
headed the couple is facing up to 20
years in prison for attempting to
launder the stolen bitcoin it's not
clear if they're the ones that actually
performed the hack back in 2016 though
documents from the department of justice
break down how they would move the
currency with a diverse array of
transactions like purchasing altcoins
and nfts and then breaking everything
down into thousands of smaller
transactions where the funds would
eventually flow into a business that
could fund heather's music videos they
get an a for effort but bitcoin's not
like a gold bar that you can just melt
down and sell on the black market on the
bright side though many of my favorite
rappers have done time in prison another
big question here is will the original
owners be able to recover their funds
bitfinex already attempted to make
customers whole by crediting them with a
different token when the hack occurred
they are working with the department of
justice but it will likely be a very
long and complicated process before
anyone gets their bitcoin back if it
happens at all but what about your
bitcoin is it safe in an exchange right
now well the blockchain network itself
is virtually unhackable with current
technology crypto exchanges on the other
hand are very much hackable the thing
about cryptocurrency is that when
someone obtains your private key they
have access to all of your money and can
send it wherever they want there's no
central authority to detect or stop
fraudulent transactions but they do
implement other measures to keep your
token safe one is multi-signature
wallets that require multiple private
keys to send a transaction the other
thing they do is try to keep as much
crypto in cold storage as possible there
are two types of crypto wallets a hot
wallet which is always connected to the
internet and ready to send transactions
and the other is a cold wallet which is
offline and generally used for long-term
storage of your money a cold wallet can
only be hacked if you have physical
possession of the device exchanges like
coinbase keep 90 of your crypto in cold
storage and because they're a big
centralized authority if they ever got
hacked they'd have enough money to pay
everybody off there are stories of
crypto exchanges being hacked all the
time but it is pretty safe for most
people today but if you're really
attached to your tokens the safest thing
to do is get them out of an exchange
into your own cold storage wallet then
move out of the city and learn how to
grow your own food dig a bunker on your
property and store the wallet there
alongside your gold and ammo this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one